Hello Freak bitches were,
I don't know if you've
heard of these guys.
Astrophysicist John mattise and Daniel
Whitmore from the University of Louisiana
came up with a theory that said that
something smaller than a Jovian mass would
not be strong enough to perform this task.
They believe that there's
something up to 25% of them.
Okay?
It's four times as big as Jupiter could
be responsible for sending these objects
and art direction.
This is just a random theory
that these guys put together.
It wasn't completely
accepted what they're doing.
No,
no,
no.
There's no,
there's no known such object what you,
what people are doing,
and I don't fault them for it.
It's creative.
It would make awesome science fiction.
Storytelling is,
there's something you need
to explain here on earth.
Somebody went extinct.
There were some wave of comets.
There's some observation
that was never repeated.
There's some thing you got to
come up with and so you say,
well,
we know the Oort cloud exists.
We know you can perturb those orbits and,
and send them careening down towards
the inner solar system and those,
that Jupiter doesn't bat
away like batting practice,
those that get through Jupiter's
gravitational shield could wreak havoc on
earth.
Yeah.
But that's,
it's,
it's inventing a lot to explain
something you don't know.
And so it's inventing more
of what you don't know.
That could be true to
explain what you don't
that which you don't have any
other evidence to support.
So it's fun,
speculation,
fun speculation.
Exactly.
Beyond that to say,
oh,
it's real,
it must be happening.
No,
no.
It's just let someone write
a good Scifi story on it.
Here's what's fun about it
and this is why I bring it up.
Um,
most people I've talked to this
about this subject to many,
many people and,
uh,
I,
myself personally,
I'm not immune to this.
I find it very fascinating.
However,
how much have I looked into the actual
planets that we absolutely know are real?
Not that much,
but I'm worried about this fucking
fake planet that may or may not exist.
Do they might've found another planet.
It's this idea of something
hidden and mysterious,
which is so compelling and attractive.
Eczema,
fascinating psychological observation.
It's a weird thing.
We want to believe there's something
mysterious that we don't understand and
could be there,
but we don't know anything about yet
where there's plenty of things we do know
something about,
but we want to know more.
Why don't you help?
Yes.
All right.
And by the way,
the universe is far more wondrous
than anything we can imagine.
And so,
so to say,
I need your creativity and you know,
uh,
to,
to keep your life interesting.
No,
we got black holes that are
flaying stars layer by layer.
We've got,
do you realize that if you
fall into a black hole,
you will see the entire future of the
universe unfold in front of you in a
matter of moments.
And you will emerge into another space
time created by the singularity of the
black hole you just fell into.
Just broke the internet,
broke the Hogan.
So,
so let's talk about that.
All right.
Yeah.
You know,
why are we wasting time talking
about whether the Saturn five rocket,
I mean,
cause we're fascinating to
buy shit that's unproven,
mysterious shit.
Look,
I got a broken brain.
Okay.
There's a reason for me.
Yeah.